welcome to this video yeah but again
okay so what do we get Queens gambit you
know doing for Queens gambit oh it's
tough to have them right in the first
game starting a new session of
five-minute games always a challenge but
okay let's see what we get here I don't
think we ever got this line on the board
Queens gambit some kind of Queens gambit
exchange cards but structure we could
have played c5 now anyway not a big not
a big deal let's play all the normals
mm-hmm so is playing all the tactic here
yeah I take this Bishop h7 Queen B 1
check those kind of ideas okay um
interesting I can actually also go for
Knight b6 in this position hmm I'm not
sure about it I don't think that the
minority attack is some is a huge
problem in this position so let's see
I've taken dan and what now maybe even
h5 and age for meeeeee okay you might
use the gphone might use the g file even
fatigue age takes now he is not getting
anything on the edge file ever so not
not quite sure about this I could have
taken on g3
okay so let's do this look at this F
porn and then to try here I don't know I
want to be quick then I have a there's a
history in the in those games where he
starts some attack which is dangerous
but ultimately not really sound and I
cannot really finish the game because
I'm taking too much time responding to
his aggressive play so I'm trying to be
quick here not because he is playing on
time or something it's just that he will
always um set some some difficult
problems and if I'm a looong time would
be difficult to handle this so okay
maybe hear and see and I go see five I
mean okay maybe he can actually play
ruka to be six and just just attack
there I was thinking that night x f4 is
even an idea his king is pretty it's
pretty bad and he's not such a great
defender I mean he's great at the
tacking but I have for my fair share of
attacking wins against him if I really
get an attack so maybe I can go for that
take on air for it looks really
ridiculous
and c5 there's f5 huh
I can see 5 f-5 94 ed for c4 is
interesting and then taking on their
forum it gives two pawns and OBT pawn
that's interesting maybe not correct but
it's definitely interesting let's see i
have Queen f4 next this is an
interesting way to play all it spawns a
week and I have some ideas like we near
three and things like that and as I said
I sometimes feel that if he has to
defend I have got my chances so we'll
take on g4 doesn't do much h3 is not
working unfortunately
yeah maybe still and then take the form
just further for the pawns but let me
just let this cover that just cover that
and then try to take before mmm very
quickly plate instead a good move it
looks kind of tricky here rookie to its
not yet working h3h3 Bishop takes
I wonder if that is a good move it just
looks wrong to me
i I don't know really that check doesn't
help brookie to not working this was my
high emergence my idea which I'm again
getting low on time
hmm it's probably fishing now but still
not so easy to play I guess
you
if i go to ph here I don't know 41
so feels kind of dangerous Quincy one
for instance losses due to Queen f3 I
think look at your guru ki three maybe
here is as possible gets dangerous
check or where they can go rookie three
first Jeremy not helping a lot hmm
cannot take them may be going over here
for okay to or get one for that matter
check check 15 seconds the position now
is kind of interesting check now it's
completely okay for me this position you
can just swing on time as usual
our fourth it's on time or whatever
whatever yeah has just spent too much
time in those games yeah okay this is
this pre sacrifice is probably not
entirely correct but it was interesting
to have the hunch that I had something
something somewhere let's check this a
little bit yeah yeah this is held really
wrong to me it looks completely
uncoordinated a groupie too but it
didn't I didn't net much or any or
anything that matter I mean I saw this
kind of line but I wasn't sure that I
have something here the computer gives
white about one pawn with this kind of
thing happening possibly okay I went
here for rookie form and queen have to
just wins yeah of course yeah I'm
playing this like an idiot really rookie
three I mean look dangerous it just I
just sis just wins yeah rook e1 aunty
it's it's over ah i'm missing so many
wins against and that's really annoying
really annoying okay rookie three check
check check point and this is of course
also alright and check now I mean here
should lose really but okay 13 seconds
is sister the issue maybe I shouldn't
have traded queens can no Angie six of
courses the drawn are due to the wrong
bishop but ok it's 11 seconds you will
play this on time of course yeah ok so I
don't know jack I really don't fare well
in those games against him if it gets
kind of messy in a strategic game I can
sometimes just win but in those kind of
yeah fistfights let's say
I miss so many chances this is really
simple once you see the move I mean here
threatening this and rookie one if he
does something like this look III is
also just winning no ah ok thanks for
watching